à coups de masse comme on leur effet au
xvième siècle des charpentiers
construisent un galio au chantier naval
alba ou la môme nord de l'espagne
c'est un projet de longue haleine notre
désir c'est de nous rendre chez vous de
nous rendre au canada et pour vous
montrer le bateau que vous avez sauvé en
1978 des archéologues de parcs canada
découvre une épave dans le port de red
bay au labrador
une découverte inespérée c'est le san
juan qui a fait naufrage en 1565 le seul
noir était l'un des nombreux navires
basque qui quittent l espagne la france
pour aller chasser les baleines à
terre-neuve-et-labrador c'était une
industrie prolifique l'huile de baleine
très prisé et est utilisé dans les
lampes pour éclairer les demeures en
europe
l'eau glaciale du port de rugby conserve
tellement bien l'épave pendant quatre
siècles que les archéologues peuvent
l'analyser et remonter quelques milliers
de pièces à la surface c'est toute une
époque de l'histoire maritime qui renaît
le pays basque est un peuple maritima
est très important et on n'était même
pas conscients de ça
depuis quatre ans la communauté suit de
près les travaux du san juan qui prend
forme grâce aux données des archéologues
canadiens plus de 60000 visiteurs ont
admiré sa construction cette année la
réplique devrait être terminé dans deux
ans prête à naviguer
comment fait-il pour se rendre à la
voile et depuis chez nous depuis le pays
basque jusqu'à jusqu'au canada
voilà et comment naviguer pile à bord du
5 juan et donc voilà il va falloir avec
notre naissance avec notre système et
petro le moyen de nous rendre chez vous
dans un an dans une réplique fidèle du
16e siècle
il équipe de marins basques souhaite
faire la traversée de l'atlantique dans
trois ans à la voile sans moteur comme
le faisait le san juan et un millier
d'autres baleiniers tous les ans mais
cette fois l'équipage ne va pas chasser
la baleine ce sera un voyage symbolique
pour renouer avec l'histoire maritime
commune des basques et des canadiennes
estime chabris de radio-canada moncton